water water everywhere in addition to
oil and gas deposits Norway's abundant
water makes it one of europe's most
important energy producers tall
mountains and high precipitation provide
ideal conditions for hydropower blow
show the country's largest reservoir
lies at an elevation of more than a
thousand metres 14 dams ensured that the
pumped storage power station connected
to it always has enough water the
turbines deep in the rock produced 2,000
megawatts an hour more than a nuclear
power station the water coming into this
turbine stock to rotate the turbine the
generator rotates and then we produce
power source in places the power station
can also store electricity to do so the
turbines pump water back up into the
mountain when needed its discharged
again and the turbines produce
electricity
the blow show the large reservoir and
the very top of the system has a stored
energy close to eight terawatt-hours
when it's filled up with water and
that's a very large battery and that
would be equal four years supply of
energy to for example stuff on your area
without no need of rain or snow with
relatively little effort energy from
Germany could also be temporarily stored
in all áfourá
for that both the German and Norwegian
electricity grids would have to be
extended much more importantly it would
require a high-capacity cable link
between the two countries the Dutch have
had access to the Norwegian grid since
2008 Denmark has several cable
connections to its neighbor in the north
a similar link to Britain is in the
planning the submarine cable to Germany
is set to be laid starting next year but
the grid operator staff net doesn't just
want to export energy to Germany the
whole idea here is to exchange power so
that when there is a surplus of wind
power and solar power in Germany we can
import that for a reasonable price and
when you haven't got Sun you haven't got
wind and you have a large demand then we
can export our hydropower for a
reasonable price to Germany the
investment costs for the link to Germany
are about 2 billion euros that would
increase the price of energy in Norway
but in the cold north heating is almost
exclusively electric no other country in
the world uses so much electricity in
Oslo the house owners Lobby Association
views the plans with skepticism
being connected to the European grid
means we also import European prices
which actually raises the price levels
here a lot and he says saving
electricity would be difficult for the
Norwegians you can stop heating heating
the pavements with electricity but I
mean in in a normal home the building is
there and it has a certain energy
quality and if you don't use the amount
of energy you need to keep it warm well
you will freeze that is a problem the
electric power companies want to make
Norway a supplier for all of Europe
activists like lesser heimdall fear that
that would have a massive impact on the
environment
there are no solution to build more
power plants the solution is finding new
technology and find the solution for
energy storing and energy saving we are
really afraid that stop craft and
similar companies will only value the
Norwegian nature according to money and
kilowatt and not kidding the value of
nature itself the right price Germany
will need the Norwegian water reservoirs
in future because it's decided to
abandon nuclear energy and the
hydropower planted una for is by no
means stretch to capacity we have
analyzed it and of course it's possible
to increase the pump storage capacity
without do doing anything with the
reservoirs with the tunnels with the
dams the country's power companies are
ready and willing in 2020 German
electricity from wind and solar energy
sources could be stored in Norway for
the first time
you